This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. The television series Never Have I Ever is a coming-of-a-wait story about the ups and downs of high school. There's popular kids, unpopular kids, and drama. There are lots and lots of crushes. And of course, there's applying for college. One of the show's main characters is an over-achiever. Ben is determined to get into his dream school, Columbia University. His schedule is packed with studying, extracurriculars and tests. Ben has no time for friends, socializing or even breakfast.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。电视剧《好想做一次》是一部关于高中生活起伏的成长故事。里面有受欢迎的孩子、不受欢迎的孩子，还有各种抓马。有数不清的暗恋。当然，还有申请大学。剧中的主角之一是个拼命三郎。本一心想要考入他梦寐以求的学校——哥伦比亚大学。他的日程排满了学习、课外活动和考试。本没有时间交朋友、社交，甚至连吃早餐的时间都没有。
Time for breakfast, my little prince. No time, Patti. I'll eat a jerky stick on the way. At school, Ben's time starts schedule, elicits eye rolls from his classmates. I have some free time between 1.15 and 2 a.m. tonight to work on this. Are you out of your mind? We're not operating on your psycho schedule. Both of you guys just come to my house after school.
该吃早餐了，我的小王子。没时间，帕蒂。我在路上吃肉干。在学校里，本这种紧凑的日程安排引得同学们直翻白眼。今天晚上1.15到2点之间我有一点空闲时间来处理这个。你疯了吗？我们可不按你那变态的日程表来。你们两个放学后直接来我家。
I can. That's what I zoom with my Mandarin teacher. Even Ben's principal has become concerned about his constant battle with time. Your schedule is untenable. You don't even have a lunch period anymore. I don't need a lunch period. Yes, I've seen you with your meat sticks.
我可以。那是我和我的普通话老师视频连线的时间。就连本的校长也开始担心他与时间的无休止搏斗。你的日程安排简直荒唐。你甚至连午休时间都没有了。我不需要午休。好吧，我见识过你吃肉干的样子。
Eventually, the stress lands Ben in the hospital. While Ben's character is exaggerated for comic effect, many people, including those who graduated high school years ago, can relate. Lofty goals, demanding jobs, and the pressures of parenthood leave many of us feeling burned out, on edge and overwhelmed. This week on Hidden Brain, how the solution to not having enough time might require us to rethink our relationship with time. When we're thinking about this resource, it makes us spend more deliberately in ways that are aligned with our values, in ways that make us feel happier.
最终，压力让本住进了医院。虽然本这个角色为了喜剧效果有些夸张，但许多人，包括那些多年前就从高中毕业的人，都能对此感同身受。崇高的目标、苛刻的工作以及为人父母的压力，让我们许多人感到筋疲力尽、焦虑不安、不知所措。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨：解决时间不够用的问题，可能需要我们重新审视自己与时间的关系。当我们思考这一资源时，它能促使我们更深思熟虑地按照自己的价值观去花费时间，从而让我们感到更快乐。
Most of us live our lives in a blur. We speed through our days, rush to drop off kids, battle work deadlines, squeeze in emails before bed. Lots of us dream of doing less, much less. We fantasize about striking it rich and quitting our jobs. At UCLA, Cassie Mogilner Holmes studies the relationship between time and well-being. Among other things, she has studied what happens to people who get their wish
我们大多数人都浑浑噩噩地过日子。我们匆忙度过每一天，赶着送孩子，应付工作截止日期，在睡前抽空回邮件。我们许多人都梦想着少做一点，少得多。我们幻想著发大财然后辞职。在加州大学洛杉矶分校，卡西·莫吉尔纳·霍姆斯研究时间与幸福感之间的关系。除此以外，她还研究了那些得偿所愿的人身上会发生什么。
to have all the time in the world. Cassie Holmes, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi, Shankar. Thank you so much for having me. This is so exciting. Cassie, I'd like to take you back to a point in your life when you had just had a baby. Your maternity leave had ended and you were on your first work trip to New York. Can you paint me a picture of what your life felt like at the time? Yes, my life felt crazy at the time. And so, yeah, when my son was four months old, I was invited to give a talk at Columbia's
拥有世上所有的空闲时间。卡西·霍姆斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嗨，香卡。非常感谢邀请我来。这太令人兴奋了。卡西，我想带你回到你人生中的一个时间点，当时你刚生完孩子。你的产假结束了，你正前往纽约进行第一次出差。你能给我描述一下当时你的生活是什么感觉吗？是的，当时我的生活简直疯了。所以，是的，当我儿子四个月大的时候，我应邀去纽约的哥伦比亚商学院作演讲，我答应了。那真是疯狂的一天，但和其他疯狂的日子也没什么两样。只是我记得非常清楚。我起得很早，赶去纽约做演讲，接着是一个接一个的会议，然后是某种同事晚宴。我从晚宴上匆忙赶出来，想要赶上最后一班能带我回费城儿子和丈夫身边的火车。
Business School up in New York and I said yes. And it was a crazy day, but not unlike other crazy days. It's just I remember quite vividly. I woke up early, traveled up to New York to give my presentation, which was followed by back-to-back meetings, and then sort of colleague dinner. And I rushed out of the dinner trying to make the very last train that would get me home to my son and my husband back in Philadelphia.
你知道的，出租车司机，纽约的出租车司机本来就开得很快，甚至太快了，但我当时在对大吼，我平时是不怎么吼人的。我说，请你快点把我送到这趟火车上。我绝对不能错过它，结果我没有错过火车，但那天晚上当我坐在火车上时，我记得自己看着窗外，黑暗从窗外呼啸而过，每个人都在家里熟睡，就像我本该在家里熟睡一样，我的丈夫和宝宝，我们在家里的睡眠在哪里。我当时意识到一切都过得太快了。身为助理教授的压力——你知道的，工作。想要成为一个好父母、好伴侣、好朋友的压力，你知道的，
And the cab driver, as you know, New York cab drivers are already driving very fast and too fast, but I was yelling at him, which I don't tend to yell. I was like, can you please hurry up to get me to this train. I cannot miss it and I didn't miss the train but when I was sitting on the train that night, I remember looking out the window and as the sort of darkness was whizzing by and everyone was asleep in their homes and just like I should have been asleep in my home and my husband and baby, where is sleep in our home. And I was realizing just how fast everything was going by. And it was such a blur between the pressures of being an assistant professors, you know, work. The pressure or wanting to be a good parent, a good partner, a good friend, you know,
加上家里堆积如山、永远做不完的家务，这一切都让人觉得难以承受。简直就是有太多事情要做。我记得当时我在想，不仅是我没有足够的时间把所有事情都做好，而且我也没有觉得能把所有事情都做好，或者在这一过程中享受其中的任何事情。所以过了一段时间，卡西，你终于得以休息一下。据我了解，你去了墨西哥旅行。
with the never-ending pile of chores that were waiting me at home, it all felt like too much. There was just simply sort of too much to do. And I remember wondering, I was like, not only do, I not have enough time to sort of do it all, I wasn't feeling like I could do it all well or enjoy any of it along the way. So sometime later Cassie you finally get to take a break. I understand you took a trip to Mexico.
情况怎么样？嗯，那是一次我非常期待的墨西哥之旅，因为那正值疯狂的日子之后，工作繁忙，还要帮孩子们做好准备、教书等等诸如此类的事情接踵而至。所以我对仅仅坐在海滩上读着书、无所事事这个想法感到无比兴奋，这听起来简直太美妙了。而且它也确实很美妙，直到第四天早上。我醒来时，你知道的，拍拍我丈夫的肩膀说，好了，我们今天打算做点什么？我受够了
How did it go? Well, it was a trip to Mexico that I was so excited about because it continued to be on the heels of crazy days, of the busyness of work and getting the kids ready and teaching and all that sort of stuff. And so I was so excited about the idea of just sitting on the beach with the book, with nothing to do, and that sounded more than delightful. And it was delightful until the morning of the fourth day. And I woke up and I was like, you know, tapping on my husband's shoulder and I'm like, all right, so what are we going to do today? I was done
无所事事，渴望重新开始行动。对我们许多人来说，这是一种感同身受的经历。我们期盼着去度假，结果过了几天却感到无聊或烦躁。就像卡西一样，我们忙碌时感到不快乐，而手头有太多空闲时间时也同样不快乐。卡西和她的同事玛丽莎·谢里夫以及哈尔·赫什菲尔德研究了拥有空闲时间（或者卡西所说的随意支配时间）与人们幸福感之间的联系。我们发现的情况很有趣，结果呈现出一种倒U型的曲线。这表明，一方面，时间太少的人是不快乐的。那就是，你知道的，那天晚上在火车上的我。但令我们惊讶的是这条弧线的另一端。
doing nothing and I was eager to get going again. For many of us, this is a relatable experience. We look forward to going on vacation, only to feel bored or antsy after a few days. Just like Cassie, we are unhappy when we are busy, and we are unhappy when we have too much time on our hands. Cassie and her colleagues, Marissa Sharif and Hal Hirschfield, have studied the connection between having free time, or discretionary time as Cassie puts it, and people's happiness. What we found was interesting, the pattern of results showed an upside down U-shape. So what that suggests is that on one end, people with two little time were unhappy. So that was, you know, me on the train that night. But what was surprising to us was the other side of that arc.
我们发现，超过一定限度后，就会出现拥有太多时间的问题。因此，当人们在一天中有大量可自由支配的小时时，他们同样会感到不满意。这几乎是一个悖论，不是吗？因为大忙人们会想象，你知道的，梦想着有一天他们可以把脚翘起来什么也不做。当然，当这一天真的到来时，
And what we found was that beyond a certain amount, there was such thing as having too much time. So when people had a whole whole lot of discretionary hours in the day, they were also dissatisfied. So it's almost a paradox, isn't it? Because very busy people imagine that, you know, the dream about the day they can just put up their feet and do nothing. And of course, when that day actually arrives,
很快，就像你发现的那样，你会发现自己感到沮丧。显然这不仅仅是你，这是一个普遍存在的现象。如何解释这个悖论呢？是的。我们的数据显示——显然这不仅仅是你，这是一个普遍存在的现象。如何解释这个悖论呢？是的，我们的数据显示，当人们在一天中有太多可自由支配的小时时，他们会觉得自己没有生产力。
very quickly, like you found, you found yourself frustrated. And this is, it's apparently not just you, it's a widespread phenomenon. What explains the paradox? Yeah. And what our data suggests is that It's apparently not just you, it's a widespread phenomenon. What explains the paradox? Yeah, and what our data suggests is that when people have too many discretionary hours in the day, they feel unproductive.
由此，这会削弱他们的目标感。随之而来的就是人们的不满。几年前，英国曾进行过一项研究，考察了数千名退休人员的认知功能。这些人曾从事过各种不同薪资水平的工作，研究人员在他们退休前14年以及退休后14年分别对这些人进行了认知记忆测试。卡西，你能告诉我他们发现了什么吗？
And from that, it undermines their sense of purpose. And with that, people are dissatisfied. A few years back, there was a study in the United Kingdom that looked at the cognitive function of thousands of retirees. These were people who had held a variety of different jobs at different salary levels and the researchers gave people a cognitive memory test 14 years before they retired and then 14 years after they retired. Can you tell me what they found Cassie?
他们的发现是，退休后，人们的认知功能在言词记忆方面出现了急剧下降。这很有趣，因为它表明当人们手头有太多可自由支配的时间时，这种时间的认知参与度和刺激性就会降低。所以这一切所指出的，我认为，
So what they found was that people's cognitive functioning decreased dramatically following retirement in terms of their verbal memory. And this is interesting because it suggests that when people have too much discretionary time on their hands, that it's less sort of cognitively engaging and stimulating. And so what this is all pointing to, I think,
是对于许多人来说，工作是获得参与感和生产力源泉——以退休人员研究为例，它提供了认知刺激、精神刺激。而如果没有这些，我们不仅会感到无聊，还会觉得失去了目标感。我们的参与度降低了，随之满意度也降低了。我们许多人过着忙碌的生活。我们匆忙赶去上班，查看电子邮件，接送孩子。我们感到自己的时间被拉长了，并幻想著有一天我们终于可以什么都不做。然而，当这一天到来时，我们经常发现自己面临着相反的问题。我们感到无聊，渴望意义和目标。无所事事和过于忙碌一样，似乎都会让我们不快乐。当我们回来时，卡西的研究将探讨我们对时间的感知
is that work for many is a source of feeling engaged, feeling productive with the retiree study. it is cognitive stimulation, mental stimulation. And without that, we're not only bored, but we feel less purpose. We are less engaged and with that less satisfied. Many of us live busy lives. We rush to work, check our email, ferry kids around. We feel our time is stretched in and we fantasize about the day when we can finally do nothing. When that day comes, however, we often find ourselves confronting the opposite problem. We are bored, hungry for meaning and purpose. Being too idle, like being too busy, seems to make us unhappy. When we come back, Cassie's research examines how our perceptions of time
如何影响我们度过时间的方式。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当大多数人被生活和工作压得喘不过气来时，我们往往会将问题归咎于我们的环境。我们会说，我有太多的截止日期摆在眼前。我有太多的承诺要履行。
influence the way we spend it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When most of us feel overwhelmed by life and by work, we tend to locate the problem in our circumstances. We say, I have too many deadlines staring me in the face. I have too many commitments on my plate.
我没有时间。当我们思考这些问题的解决方案时，我们经常求助于白日梦和幻想。也许我会中彩票，就不用再工作了。也许我可以逃到一个热带小岛上，在那里我唯一的责任就是坐在椰子树下啜饮玛格丽塔酒。在加州大学洛杉矶分校，心理学家卡西·霍姆斯在2017年的某一天有了这样的经历，当时她正带着一个学龄前儿童在校园里匆忙赶路。
I have no time. When we think about the solutions to these problems, we often resort to daydreams and fantasy. Maybe I'll win the lottery and won't have to work anymore. Maybe I could run away to a tropical island where my only responsibility is to sit under a coconut tree and sip magridas. At UCLA, psychologists Cassie Holmes has come one day in 2017, as she was racing across campus with a preschooler in tow.
我没有很长的通勤路程。我可以带着我三岁的孩子穿过美丽的加州大学洛杉矶分校校园送他去上学，然后我去上班。特别是一个早晨，阳光灿烂。那是一个春日。小鸟在歌唱，我的儿子一蹦一跳地开心极了。而我却在大步流星地往前赶，因为我在想着那个我会迟到的会议，还想着送完他之后那天要做的一大堆事情。
I didn't have a long commute. I could walk through beautiful UCLA campus with my three-year-olds to take him to preschool and me to work. And there was one morning in particular where the sun was shining. It was a spring day. And the birds were chirping and my sun was skipping along as happy as could be. And I was charging ahead because I was thinking about the meeting that I was going to be late to and also thinking about all the things that I had to do that day when I dropped him off.
我听到他喊道，妈妈，停下。我说，我们没有时间停下来，快走。他说，妈妈，请停下。我转过身看到他的鼻子埋在一丛玫瑰花里。我不假思索地脱口而出这样的话。我说，我们没有时间停下来闻闻玫瑰花香。听到这些话时，我确实停了下来。我想，天哪，我太沉浸在自己的世界里了，我太想着接下来要做什么了，以至于对眼前的这幅完美景象视而不见，而我的儿子却切切实实注意到了。作为一个时间和幸福感的研究人员和专家，
And I heard him, he was like, mom, stop. And I was like, we don't have time to stop hurry up. And he's like, mom, please stop. And I turn around and I see that he has nose is buried in a bush of roses. And I, without thinking, these words came out of my mouth. I was like, we don't have time to stop and smell the roses. And when I heard those words, I did stop. I was like, oh, my gosh, I am so in my head, I am so thinking about what's next that I was oblivious to this perfect scene that I was in, that my son was absolutely noticing. And as a time and happiness researcher and expert,
对着空气大喊我们没有时间停下来闻闻玫瑰花香，绝对是一个警钟。你能做的最重要的事情是什么？在她的实验室里，卡西开始反思自己是否在生活中把问题搞错了。当她想到自己是一个年轻的职场妈妈，面临着来自工作和家庭的种种时间压力时，她感到压力巨大。但问题真的是缺乏时间吗？
yelling into the air that we don't have time to stop and smell the roses was definitely a wake up call. What is the most important thing that you can do? In her lab, Cassie began to ask whether she had defined the problem wrong in her own life. When she thought about being a young working mom and the many pressures on her time at work and at home, it felt really stressful. But was the problem a lack of time?
还是她看待时间的方式？她决定将科学工具应用到自己的生活中，并密切追踪自己是如何度过每一天的。时间追踪的作用是，你写下自己在做什么——追踪的作用是，你写下自己每半小时在做什么，你正在进行的活动是什么，不要那么笼统地说“我在工作”，而是具体你在工作做什么，你在做什么项目，也不要那么笼统地说“哦，这是家庭时间”，你在那段家庭时间里到底在做什么？不仅要写下你在做什么，这很重要，而且我还会用10分制来评估我有多快乐，有多喜悦，有多满足。
Or the way she was thinking about time? She decided to apply the tools of science to her own life and to closely track how she was spending her days. What time tracking does is that you write down what you're doing tracking does is that you write down what you're doing every half hour, what's the activity you're doing, and not being so broad like I'm at work, but in particular, what are you doing at work, what project are you working on, and not so broad as, oh, it's family time, what are you doing during that family time? And it's important to not just write what you're doing, but I also rate on a 10-point scale, how happy, how joyful, how satisfying I feel
通过度过这段时间。这样，朗顿就可以回顾并拥有自己的个性化数据集，捕捉他们是如何度过时间的，这使他们能够提炼出哪些活动往往能为他们带来最大程度的幸福？哪些活动往往能为他们带来最少程度的幸福？除此之外，不仅是具体的活动，还有这些最快乐的活动和最不快乐的活动之间有哪些共同点？这些最快乐的活动和最不快乐的活动。这也让你能够看到自己在这些各种类型的活动上花費了多少时间。
on having spent that time. So, London can look back and have their own personalized data set that captures how they're spent their time and it allows them to pull out what are those activities that tend to produce the greatest amount of happiness for them? What are those activities that tend to produce the least amount of happiness for them? In addition to that, not just the particular activities, but what are some commonalities across those happiest activities and those least happy activities? those happiest activities and those least happy activities. And what this also allows you to do is see just how much time you're spending across these various types of activities.
现在，当卡西谈到选择能带来幸福的活动时，并不是说我们唯一的选择就是做那些让我们快乐的事，或者做那些让我们不快乐的事。我们所有人都必须例行公事般地做一些并不好玩的事情。我们不能说，哦，我永远不会打扫我的房子或洗碗或去看牙医。时间追踪可以向你展示的是，你可能没有有效地分配你的时间。想象一下，你的生活被划分为不同的隔间。有些事情你做了
Now when Cassie talks about choosing activities that produce happiness, it's not like she's saying that our only choices are to do things that make us happy or do things that make us unhappy. All of us routinely have to do things that are not fun. It's not like we can say, oh, I'm never going to clean my house or do the dishes or go to the dentist. What time tracking can show you is that you might not be allocating your time efficiently. Imagine your life was divided into different compartments. There are things that you do
既有趣又有意义，比如花时间在一个有启发性的工作项目上。然后是一些你不是非做不可，但你很享受的事情。比如和朋友闲逛或去度假。第三类活动可能是你必须要做的事情，即使它们并不令人愉快。杂务就属于这一类。但当卡西追踪她的时间时，她意识到她在杂务上花费的时间超过了需要的时间。嗯，有很多时间可以说是被浪费了。
that are both fun and meaningful, maybe time spent on a stimulating project at work. Then there's stuff you don't have to do, but that you enjoy. Like hanging out with friends or going on a vacation. A third group of activities might be things you have to do, even if they are not enjoyable. Chores fall into the category. But as Cassie tracked her time, she realized she was spending more time that she needed to on chores. Well, there was a lot of time that I would say was wasted.
特别是，我浪费时间的根源在于我花在电子邮件、回复收件箱以及试图处理完它们上的时间，不仅是在工作日，甚至在晚上也是如此。因此，看看我的快乐评分，我在那个特定的活动上花时间并不是很高兴。我在时间追踪数据中观察到的是，当我花时间一对一地与我爱的人进行那种良好的连接对话时，我是最快乐的，无论是周末结束时我和丈夫出去吃晚饭，远离厨房的清理工作，不去处理我们生活中的育儿后勤杂务，而是真正进行那种最初将我们吸引到彼此身边的对话。当我跟女儿闲逛，我们一边喝着咖啡（对我来说）或热巧克力（对她来说）一边聊天时。当我进行某种精彩的、丰富的
And in particular, my source of waste of time is the amount of time I spend on email and responding to my inbox and trying to get through it, not just in the work day, but also in the evenings. And so, and looking at my happiness ratings, I was not very happy spending my time on that particular activity. What I observed in my time tracking data is that I am happiest when I'm spending time one-on-one having that good connecting conversation with the people I love, whether it is my husband at the end of the week when we have gone out to dinner away from the kitchen cleanup and are not going through the logistics of
与我的一个研究合作者的谈话，走过加州大学洛杉矶分校美丽的校园去买咖啡或我最喜欢的珍珠奶茶，你知道的，听他们讲他们的生活以及谈论研究。我的意思是，没有什么比这更让人高兴的了。当卡西像科学家一样追踪她的时间时，她开始发现她和学龄前儿童闻玫瑰花香时的顿悟指向了更宏大的东西。在各种意义上，她并没有分配她的时间
parenting in our lives and actually having the conversation that drew us to each other in the first place. When I'm hanging out with my daughter and we are chatting over a cup of coffee for me, hot chocolate for her. When I'm having a wonderful sort of enriching
来最大化那些能促进幸福的活动。她让那些她并不享受但觉得不得不做的事情侵入了留作放松和恢复精力的时间。她在访问意大利期间深刻地注意到了这一点。我们去了托斯卡纳，太棒了。这是一个星期的时间，我们特意抽出来不工作，不处于那种“待办”模式，只是纯粹度假。
conversation with one of my research collaborators, walking across the beautiful UCLA's campus to get coffee or my preferred bubble tea, you know, hearing about their lives as well as talking about research. I mean, there's nothing more joyful than that. As Cassie tracked her time like a scientist, she started to see the epiphany she'd had with her preschoolers smelling the roses, pointed to something much bigger. In all sorts of ways, she was not allocating her time
是的，我发现自己在傍晚时分看着托斯卡纳的乡间景色，这个美丽的日落，而我脑子里想的却是计划我们明天要做的事情并进行协调，偷偷摸摸地用手机试图协调我们什么时候去接车去下一个小镇。比杂务侵入促进幸福的活动更糟糕的是，时间追踪可以显示你在既不
to maximize activities that promoted happiness. She was allowing things she didn't enjoy, but felt she had to do, to intrude on time, set aside for relaxation and rejuvenation. She noticed this acutely during a visit to Italy. We went to Tuscany, which was so wonderful. And this was one week that we were carving out to not do work, to not be in that due mode and just be on vacation.
重要也不快乐的事情上花费了多少时间。把时间花在这样的活动上简直毫无意义。我记得其中一个学生，她在全职工作的同时，在晚上和周末攻读学位，她非常忙碌。是的，当她查看一周的数据时，她意识到自己在社交媒体上花费了十几个小时。看着她的评分，她说，天哪，这太多了，考虑到她有多忙。看着她给出的评分，你知道的，就像3分和4分，
Yeah, I found myself in the evening looking over, you know, the Tuscany countryside, this beautiful sunset, and what was going on in my head was planning for what we were going to be doing tomorrow and coordinating that and sort of sneaking onto my phone to try to coordinate when we were gonna be picked up to go to the next little town. Even worse than chores and truding on activities that promote happiness, time tracking can show how much time you are spending on things that are neither
而那些她觉得自己太忙而没时间去做，但在幸福感方面能得到9分或10分的活动，是下班后和她姐姐见面吃晚饭。我认为这凸显了关于忙碌的一点——我们觉得自己太忙而没时间做那些对我们真正重要、真正能让我们感到快乐的事情，
essential nor joyful. Spending time on such activities makes absolutely no sense. One of my students I remember in particular who, while working towards her degree on the nights and weekends, while working full-time, she was so busy. Yeah, when she looked at the data from her week, she realized that she spent a dozen hours on social media. And looking at her ratings, she's like, holy cow, that is so much, particularly given how busy she is. And looking at the ratings that she gave, you know, it's like three and four,
我们觉得自己太忙而没时间做这些，然而却有那么多时间在盲目、充满露西式（无意识）的滑动中消磨掉，这是社交媒体上的那些事情之一，人们认为，你知道的，我只是看一眼。只需要几分钟，但不可避免地，几分钟变成了几十分钟，然后这几十分钟在几天的过程中累积成数小时又数小时。对于我们这些感到极度缺乏时间的人来说，认识到这一点很重要，因为这表明我们可以将部分时间重新分配到哪里，这样我们就可以把更多时间花在快乐的时刻上。卡西还注意到，当她没有用心对待自己如何度过时间时，她会在快乐的时刻。
whereas the activities that she feels too busy that she doesn't have time to do, but gets, you know, a nine or 10 in terms of happiness, is meeting up with her sister after work for dinner. And what I think that highlights with respect to the busyness that we feel too busy to do these things that really matter to us and can really make us feel joyful
卡西还注意到，当她没有用心对待自己如何度过时间时，她就会开始多任务处理。即使在她做那些需要做且热爱做的事情时，她的心思也会飘到别处。有一次，卡西注意到自己在一场关于分心风险的科学演讲中也是如此。这实在是太切中要害了。作为一名教授，我们工作的一大乐趣就是可以去参加研究研讨会，其他教职员工会来分享我们正在研究的研究成果。
that we're too busy to do those yet so many hours just get mind-lucy-filled, scrolling, and it's one of those things on social media that people think, you know, I'm just going to check. It'll just be a couple minutes, but inevitably a couple minutes turns into, you know, tens of minutes, but then those tens of minutes over the course of days sum up to hours and hours. And for those of us who feel so time poor, this is important to recognize because it suggests where can we reallocate some of our time so that we can spend more on moments of joy. Cassie also noticed that when she was not mindful about how she spent her time, she on moments of joy.
这令人高兴，因为我们可以了解科学界正在发生的事情。有一个引人入胜的演讲，研究人员分享了驾驶员在手机上分心的危险。因此，开车时分心看手机甚至比酒后驾车或醉酒驾驶更致命、更危险。当他告诉我们手机分心的危险时，我分心了。
Cassie also noticed that when she was not mindful about how she spent her time, she would start to multitask. Even when she was doing things that she needed to do and loved to do, her mind would be somewhere else. One time, Cassie noticed herself doing this as she was listening to a scientific presentation on the risks of distraction. It was just so sort of on the nose. As a professor, one of the joys of our work is that we get to go to research seminars where other faculty will come and share the research that we're working on.
我在手机上点着头，假装在听，但实际上我在亚马逊上浏览我的待办事项清单，为我儿子那一周要参加的生日派对订购礼物和包装纸，并给他的足球队团队发邮件，询问谁来带零食。所以我被拉出了这个本可以非常丰富和富有启迪性的体验，因为我被我的待办事项清单分心了。我们对如何部署时间的用心程度越低，我们感到的压力和日程安排过满的情况就越严重。这不仅对我们的个人幸福有影响，还会影响我们对别人的行为以及别人对我们的行为。
And it's joyful because we get to learn what is happening in science. And there was this fascinating presentation where the researcher was sharing the dangers of being distracted on cell phones among drivers. So being distracted on the cell phone while driving is more deadly, more dangerous than even driving, inebriated or drunk. And while he was telling us about the dangers of being distracted on our phones, I was distracted.
20世纪70年代的一项著名研究证明了这一点。它围绕着圣经中的一个寓言，即好撒玛利亚人停下来帮助另一个陷入困境的人。这是一项非常有趣的研究，对象是人们可能遇到最善良的人之一，对吧？神学院学生。他们的任务是将好撒玛利亚人的故事讲给大厅尽头房间里的其他人听。在他们离开的路上，一些参与者被告知他们迟到了，他们没有太多时间。在他们去的路上，实际上
And on my phone, I was nodding, trying to pretend that I was listening, but instead I was on Amazon going through my to-do list of ordering a gift and wrapping paper for my son to go to a birthday party that week and emailing the team, his soccer team, about, you know, who's gonna bring the snacks. So I was being pulled out of this experience that could have been really enriching and illuminating because I was distracted by my to-do list. The less mindful we are about how we deploy our time, the more we feel stressed out and over-scheduled. This has implications not just for our personal happiness, but how we behave toward others and how others behave toward us.
路边有一个人在咳嗽，明显需要帮助，参与者并不知道，他是为研究而被雇佣的卧底演员，但研究人员正在观察的是，一个被告知自己迟到了、觉得自己赶时间的人，是否会停下来提供帮助。事实上，他们发现当人们感到自己时间紧迫时，他们不太可能停下来帮助别人。据我所知，你进行了一项研究，也发现了类似的效果。是这样吗，卡西？是的。我在大学生中进行了一项研究，
A famous study in the 1970s demonstrated this. It centered around a parable from the Bible, the Good Samaritan, who stops to help another person in distress. This is a really interesting study and conducted among the kindest individuals one could come across, right? Seminary students. And their task was to present the story of the good Samaritan to others in a room that was down the hall. On their way out some of the participants were told that they were late, that they didn't have a lot of time. And on their way there was actually
只是引导他们思考自己有多忙或不忙。我让他们写一段关于他们那天有多忙以及有多少事情要做的短文，而对照组只是让他们写写自己的一天。然后我问他们是否愿意多留15分钟，通过帮一个高中生修改大学申请论文来提供帮助。我发现仅仅思考一个人的忙碌程度就会让人们不太愿意花时间去帮助别人。因此，我们已经看到了时间稀缺感可以改变我们对他人的态度、改变我们的行为的许多方式。
a man on the side who was coughing clearly in need of help, unbeknownst to the participants, he was someone who was hired as a Confederate for the study, but what the researchers were looking at is whether someone who was told that they were late, who felt like they were in a hurry, would be likely to stop and help. And indeed, they found when people felt they were, had scarce time, they were less likely to stop and help someone. I understand that you've conducted a study and found a similar effect. Is that correct, Cassie? Yeah. Well, I conducted a study among college students,
我们尚未讨论的一点是，时间稀缺在某种程度上是一个陷阱。它让我们做出的选择很可能会在未来增加我们的时间稀缺性。心理学家描述了一种叫做“是的，该死”效应的现象。这是什么，卡西？是的，这很重要。这是一个需要记住的重要研究。格尔斯、奥伯曼和约翰·林奇，他们所做的是
simply leading them to think about how busy or not that they are. And I had them write a paragraph about how busy and how many things they have to do that day versus a control condition where they just wrote about their day. And then I asked them whether they would be willing to stay an extra 15 minutes to help out a high schooler by editing their college application essay. And what I found was simply thinking about one's busyness made people less likely to be willing to spend the time to help another. So, we've looked at lots of ways that the feeling of time scarcity can change our attitudes toward others, change our behavior.
他们让人们思考今天以及今天必须要做的一切事情和白天的忙碌。他们还让他们思考一个月后的那个月的同一天。不可避免地，人们认为一个月后他们会有比今天更多的可用时间。但这是绝对不正确的，因为认为一个月后会有更多可用时间会导致当你被要求做事情时，你会说“好”。你会想，当然，一个月后我会把零食带到那个活动上去，因为我知道，你知道的，虽然我今天很忙，但我肯定会有比——是的，我会为那个会议做个演讲，
One thing we haven't discussed is how time scarcity in some ways is a trap. It sets us up to make choices that will likely increase our time scarcity in the future. Psychologists describe something called the yes, damn effect. What is this, Cassie? Yeah, this is important. It's an important study to remember. Gulls, Obermann, and John Lynch, what they did
因为我会有比这更多的时间，但当然我今天绝对没有时间做这件事。通过这种偏见，认为我们未来会有更多可用时间，我们在未来会比今天不那么忙，我们接受了这些承诺，当那一天到来时，在未来可用，我们在未来会比今天不那么忙，我们接受了这些承诺，当那一天到来时，
was they asked people to think about today and all that they have to do today and the busyness of the day. And they also ask them to think about that same day of the month, one month from now. And inevitably, people thought that they will have more time available one month from now than they do today. But that's absolutely not true because what thinking that you'll have more time available one month from now does is that when you are asked to do things, you say yes. You're like, sure, I will bring the snacks to that event in a month because I, you know, like, while I'm busy today, I will surely have more time than, yes, I will give a talk for that conference
也就是我们答应了，然后当那一天到来时，我们说“该死”，因此有了“是的，该死”效应。你知道几年前，我在普林斯顿大学采访埃尔达·沙菲尔时，我告诉他我有多忙，压力有多大，他说，我给你一条规则。如果有人建议你两个月后做某件事，你应该问自己，我今天能做这件事吗？如果是今天，我能做到吗？如果对这个问题的回答是否定的，你应该对两个月后的那件事说不，因为据推测，两个月后你不会变得不那么忙。所以我说，好吧，这是一个伟大的规则。我开始把它叫做“埃尔达规则”。但后来我问埃尔达，你多久遵循一次“埃尔达规则”？他说，我从不遵循它。
because I will have more time than, but of course there's no way I would have time to do that today. And by thinking, having this bias that we think we will have more time available in the future, that we will be less busy in the future than we are today, we take on these commitments that when the day comes, available in the future that we will be less busy in the future than we are today, we take on these commitments that when the day comes, that is, we've said yes, and then when the day comes, we say damn, hence the yes, damn effect.
所以卡西，知道这种偏见存在是一回事，真正采取行动则是另一回事。是的。我实际上会通过一个不同的过滤器来看待它，不仅是你认为自己今天有多忙与那时候相比有多忙，而是那个任务或请求是否是你今天想做的事情？它看起来是否值得，因为当你觉得“哦，当然，以后再说”时，很容易对事情说“是”，因为你不那么珍视你的时间
You know several years ago, I was interviewing Eldarsha Fier at Princeton University, and I was telling you how busy I was, how stressed out I was, and he said, let me give you a rule. If someone suggests you do something two months from now, you should ask yourself, can I do that thing today? If it was today, would I be able to do it? And if the answer to that question is no, you should say no to the thing that's two months from now because presumably you're not going to be any less busy two months from now. So I said, okay, that's a great rule. I started calling it the LDAR rule. But then I asked LDAR, how often do you follow the LDAR rule? And he said, I never follow it.
在未来，而是使用某种目的过滤器或幸福过滤器：如果今天有人要求我这样做，我会拒绝吗？不仅因为我太忙，而是因为这是一件我不想做且觉得不值得我花时间的事情。嗯。换句话说，我们不仅打折了我们未来将有多忙，
So it's one thing Cassie, to know that the bias exists, it's another thing to actually do something about it. Yeah. And I would actually sort of put it through a different filter, which it's not only how busy do you think you are today versus will be then, is is that task something or that request something that you want to do today? That it seems worthwhile because it's very easy to say yes to things when you're like, oh sure later because you don't value your time quite so much
在某种程度上，我们通过说“是的，这并不是特别愉快，但我先应承下来，我未来的自己会处理的”，从而对我们未来自己的幸福打了折扣。正是如此。当我们回来时，如何重新校准你与时间的关系。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们大多数人对待时间的方式就像对待金钱一样。我们的供应是有限的，如果我们能拥有更多，生活就会变得更好。
in the future, but using a sort of purpose filter or a happiness filter of, if I were asked to do this today, would I say no, not just because I'm too busy, but because it's something that I don't wanna do and doesn't feel worth my time. Mm-hmm. So in other words, we not only discount how busy we're going to be in the future,
在加州大学洛杉矶分校，卡西·霍姆斯发现了我们在思考时间方式上的许多悖论。首先，事情太少的人往往和事情太多的人一样不快乐。其次，当我们觉得没有时间时，它会改变我们的行为。它让我们较少关注他人。它让我们无法享受身边的美好事物。它促使我们做出或多或少保证我们在未来会超负荷和精疲力竭的决定。在她的书《快乐时光》中，卡西提出了一种截然不同的时间思考方式。卡西，你曾经让志愿者在周末开始前对他们的周末进行不同的思考。你对他们的指令是什么？你发现了什么？
and some ways we discount the happiness of our future selves by saying, yes, this is not really particularly enjoyable, but I'll just pass that off, and my future self will take care of it. Exactly. When we come back, how to recalibrate your relationship with your time. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Most of us think about time the same way we think about money. We have a limited supply of it and life would be better if we only had more.
是的，在周末来临之际的职场成年人样本中，我们随机安排一些人将那个周末当作假期来对待。而对于其他人，我们告诉他们把那个周末当作普通周末来对待。你发现了什么？我们在他们周一返回工作岗位时对他们进行了回访，以衡量他们的幸福感。我们发现，那些仅仅被指示把周末当作假期对待的人，在周一返回工作岗位时更快乐，他们也更享受那个周末。我们对是什么推动了这一点很感兴趣，人们花时间的方式是否不同？
At UCLA, Cassie Holmes has discovered a number of paradoxes in the way we think about time. First, people who have too little to do are often as unhappy as people who have too much. Second, when we feel we have no time, it changes our behavior. It makes us focus less on others. It keeps us from enjoying wonderful things around us. It prompts us to make decisions that more or less guarantee we will be overstretched and exhausted in the future. In her book, Happy Hour Hour, Cassie suggests there's a radically different way to think about time. Cassie, you once asked volunteers to think differently about their weekends right before
我们确实发现人们花时间的方式有轻微的差异。因此，把周末当作假期对待的人确实少花了一点时间做家务，少花了一点时间做实际工作。他们花在吃饭上的时间更长，比如坐在餐桌旁，他们花在床上的时间与伴侣在一起的时间多了一点。所以这些都是，你知道的，像度假一样的活动，但并不是说他们不做任何工作，也不是说他们不做任何家务。有趣的是，他们在周末所做的活动实际上并没有显着影响他们周一返回工作岗位时的感受。真正推动幸福感改变的是他们的心态。因此，那些把周末当作假期对待的人
the weekend started. What were your instructions to them and what did you find? Yes, among a sample of working adults leading into the weekend, we randomly assigned some to treat that weekend like a vacation. And the others, we told them to treat that weekend like a regular weekend. What did you find? We followed up with them on Monday when they returned to work to measure how happy they are. And what we found was that those who were simply instructed to treat their weekend like a vacation were happier on Monday when they were back at work and they had enjoyed the weekend more. And we were interested in what drove this, did people spend their time differently,
对他们正在做的活动更有投入感。他们更多地处于当下，这让他们能够更好地享受这段时间，进而由于更享受周末、完全投入其中，而不是被所有逼近我们的工作或家务分心，这让他们在周一开始工作时能够更快乐。我经常注意到，当我出国旅行或去某个新城市时，你知道的，
and we did find that people, there were slight differences in how people spent their time. So those who treated the weekend like a vacation did spend a little bit less time doing housework, a little bit less time doing actual work. They spent longer eating, so sitting at the dinner table, they spent a little bit more time in bed with their partner. So these are things that are, you know, activities that are like being on vacation, but it's not like they didn't do any work and it's not like they didn't do any housework. What was interesting too was that what the activities that they did over the weekend actually didn't significantly influence how they felt when they returned to work on Monday. What did drive that change in happiness was their mindset. So those who were treating the weekend like a vacation
你在欣赏一切，在吸收一切，你双眼圆睁，但如果你看看当地人，你知道的，他们经常行色匆匆去上班，对通勤感到厌烦。他们看到的城市和你看到的是同一个，但当然，你的体验完全不同。同样，当你在自己的家乡看到游客时，游客们站在那里给那些你每天走过却从未停下来看一眼的建筑物拍照，更不用说给它拍照了。
were more engaged in the activities they were doing. They were more in the present, which allowed them to enjoy that time more, and which then having enjoyed their weekend more, being fully engaged, not being distracted by all of the work or all of the chores that are looming over waiting for us, it allowed them to be happier when they return to work on Monday. I've often noticed when I travel overseas or to a new city somewhere, you know,
在某种程度上，这正是卡西你所谈论的观点。作为我们自己生活中的游客，这种体验在某种程度上让我们敞开心扉，让我们注意到并留心周围发生的事情。绝对是的。我们在生活常规中所受到的影响是，我们习惯了它。我们对享乐适应的倾向，被称为享乐适应，也就是说在重复接触后，我们不再那么注意到它。当坏事发生时，这种适应是好的，因为它让我们有韧性。但面对生活中的快乐时，它就没那么好了，因为我们不再那么注意到它们。
you're taking in everything and you're absorbing everything and your eyes are wide open, but you look at the people who are the locals, you know, they're often hurrying around, getting to work, bored with their commutes. And they're seeing the same city that you're seeing, but of course, your experience of it is completely different. And similarly, when you're in your home city and you see tourists, the tourists are standing around taking pictures of buildings that you walk by every day and you've never stopped to look at the building, let alone take a picture of it.
你知道的，如果你回想一下你的伴侣第一次对你说的“我爱你”。你知道的，你的心因幸福而爆棚。然后在结婚10年后，“我爱你”已经被缩短成了“爱妳”，作为早晨告别的一种方式。你甚至听不到这些话。所以，当事情每天都在发生时，它们每天都在发生，我们没有注意到，我们正在错失我们日常经验中那些触手可及的快乐所带来的潜在喜悦。卡西开始反问，还有其他技术能让人改变与时间的关系吗？在一项研究中，她给志愿者布置了一组任务，并要求其中一些人思考时间，另一些人思考金钱。
And in some ways that's speaking to exactly the idea that you're talking about Cassie. There's something about being a tourist in our own lives that in some ways opens us up and makes us pay attention and be mindful of what's happening around us. Absolutely. The thing that we're subject to in the routine of our lives is that we get used to it. Our tendency to hedonically adapt, it's called hedonic adaptation, that is after repeated exposure, we stop noticing it as much. This is good that we adapt when bad things happen because it makes us resilient. But it's not so good in the face of, you know, joys in our life because we don't notice them as much.
我发现，那些被引导去思考时间的人与对照组和金钱组相比，实际上计划参与那些更快乐的活动，即涉及社交联系或能让他们感到满足的活动。然而，当人们被引导去思考金钱时，它实际上导致他们计划花更多的时间工作。换句话说，改变你度过时间的方式的方法之一就是简单地问问自己是如何度过时间的。卡西发现，一旦人们进入思考时间的思维状态，他们的行为也会发生改变。在我的工作中，我不仅
You know, if you think about the first time your partner said, I love you. You know, your heart is bursting with happiness. And then 10 years on in a marriage, I love you. It has been shortened to love you as a way to sort of say goodbye in the morning. And you don't even hear the words. So there is something that when things happen every day, they feel every day and we don't notice and we're missing out on the potential joy from those pleasures that are right there in our daily experience. Cassie started to ask, are there other techniques to get people to change their relationship to time? In one study, she gave volunteers a set of tasks and asked some of them to think about time and some of them to think about money.
你知道，如果你回想伴侣第一次对你说“我爱你”的时候，你知道，你的内心充满了幸福。而当婚姻走过十年之后，“我爱你”这三个字缩短成了“爱哦”，成了早晨道别的一种方式。甚至连你自己都听不到这些字眼了。因此，当某些事情天天发生时，它们就变得稀松平常，以至于我们注意不到，从而错失了那些藏在我们日常生活体验中、本可以带来的潜在快乐。卡西开始思考，是否还有其他技巧能让人们改变他们与时间的关系？在一项研究中，她给志愿者布置了一组任务，并要求其中一部分人思考时间，另一部分人思考金钱。
What I found was that those who were them to think about time and some of them to think about money. What I found was that those who were led to think about time compared to a control condition and a money condition actually plan to engage in activities that were happier activities, so involving social connection or those activities that made them feel fulfillment. Whereas when people were led to think about money, it actually led them to plan to spend more time doing work. In other words, one way to change the way you spend your time is to simply ask yourself how you are spending your time. Cassie has found that once people are put into a state of mind where they are thinking about time, their behavior changes too. In my work, I didn't just
我发现，那些被引导去思考时间的人——与对照组和金钱组相比——实际上计划从事那些能带来更多快乐的活动，比如涉及社交联系的活动，或是能让他们感到满足的活动。然而，当人们被引导去思考金钱时，这实际上促使他们计划花更多的时间来工作。换句话说，改变你花时间方式的一种方法，就是简单地问问自己你是如何花时间的。卡西发现，一旦人们进入思考时间的精神状态，他们的行为也会随之改变。在我的工作中，我不仅
want to see how people plan to spend their time. I also wanted to see how thinking about time versus many would influence people's actual behavior. So I went to a coffee shop as a place where, you know, people are socially connecting, it's spending time with others, which is an activity that's associated with greater happiness. And people also, you know, are on their laptops working. On the way into the cafe, I asked them to complete a survey, which surreptitiously exposed them to time-related words or many related words. And then, unbeknownst to the participants, we watched how they spent their time in the cafe. And
想看看人们计划如何度过他们的时间。我还想看看思考时间与思考金钱会如何影响人们的实际行为。所以我去了一家咖啡馆，因为你知道，这是一个人们进行社交连接的地方，是与他人共度时光的地方，这是一种能带来更大幸福感的活动。而且人们也都在用笔记本电脑工作。在进入咖啡馆的路上，我请他们完成了一份问卷，问卷无意中让他们接触到了与时间相关的词汇或与金钱相关的词汇。然后，在参与者不知情的情况下，我们观察了他们在咖啡馆里是如何度过时间的。而
what we found was that those who were led to think about time spent a greater proportion of their time at the cafe, connecting with others. So chatting with others in line, talking to others in the space, versus those who are actually led to think about many, spend a greater proportion of their time working. And so I think what this research shows is that thinking about our time, being more thoughtful
我们发现的是，那些被引导去思考时间的人，在咖啡馆里花更多的时间与他人交流。比如在队伍中与他人聊天，在空间里与他人交谈，而那些被引导去思考金钱的人，则把更多的时间花在工作上。所以我觉得这项研究表明的是，思考我们的时间，对我们生活中的这一资源更有深思熟虑
and intentional about this resource that is our life, right? How we spend our minutes, add up to our hours, or years, or decades in our life, overall. And when we're thinking about this resource, it makes us spend more deliberately in ways that are aligned with our values, in ways that make us feel happier. I understand that you've sometimes had volunteers do a rather unusual exercise, which is to write their own eulogies. Why would you ask them to do this, Cassie? Yeah, what writing your eulogy does is it leads you to think, take that broader perspective of your time,
和更有意图，对吧？我们如何度过我们的分钟，汇聚成我们的生活中的小时、年或几十年，总体而言。当我们思考这一资源时，它促使我们更刻意地按照符合我们价值观的方式去消费，以让我们感到更快乐的方式。我听说你有时会让志愿者做一个相当不同寻常的练习，那就是写他们自己的悼词。你为什么要让他们这样做，卡茜？是的，写你的悼词的作用是，它引导你去思考，对你的时间采取更宏观的视角，
thinking about your life as a whole. So it is how at the end of your life do you wanna be remembered? What legacy do you wanna leave? And by articulating that, writing out a eulogy that you would hope that will be presented about you, what it clarifies is, is what are those aspects of you that are really important? What are those words that you hope people use to describe you? What are your values? And by thinking about that, what life do you wanna live, that can inform how you spend your hours today. is called the Times Left Exercise. So if you reflect back on your past week
把你的生活作为一个整体来思考。所以，这就是在你的生命尽头，你希望人们如何记住你？你想要留下什么遗产？通过明确这一点，写下一篇你希望别人为你宣读的悼词，它所阐明的是，那些真正重要的关于你的方面是什么？你希望人们用哪些词来描述你？你的价值观是什么？通过思考这些，你想过什么样的生活，这可以指导你今天如何度过你的时间。这被称为“剩余时间练习”。因此，如果你回顾过去的一周
and identify what was a moment of joy, oftentimes it's a very ordinary experience. And so what I encourage people to do is count how many times have you done that in your life so far, and then to count how many times do you have left to do it in your life? An example here is I had, I have my students do this, and one of my students,
并找出哪个是快乐的时刻，通常这是一种非常平常的体验。所以我鼓励人们做的是，计算一下到目前为止你在生活中已经做了多少次，然后计算一下在你的生活中你还剩下多少次可以做这件事？这里的一个例子是，我让我的学生做这个，我的一个学生，
whom, his interlate 20s getting her MBA, counted her dinners with her parents. And what she calculated, thinking about, you know, from her childhood, other than the study, you know, summer that she was studying abroad in high school. And then counting when she went off to college, visits home, and then when she was living in on the other side of the country for work, when her parents would come out to visit, and then she moved back to California to actually be closer to her parents, and they had Sunday night dinners. And she counted all of those up and realized that she had about 6,800 dinners with her parents thus far in her life.
她快20岁了，正在读MBA，她计算了她与父母共进晚餐的次数。她计算得出，考虑到她的童年，除了高中时她出国交换的那年夏天。然后计算她去上大学、回家探亲，以及后来为了工作住在国家另一端时父母来看望她，然后她搬回加州以便离父母更近，他们有周日晚上的晚餐。她把这些全部加起来，意识到到目前为止在她的人生中，她大约和父母吃过6800次晚餐。
And then, inculculating how many dinners that she likely have left, she counted that she had about 575 dinners left, that is she had only 8% of her dinners with her parents left. And that's impactful because what it does is it leads her to a make the time. No matter how busy she feels, that she with that recognition, she is going to show up for the Sunday night dinner. But even beyond that, at the dinners, it changes how she engages in that time. You know, like her mom's what she used to view as nagging comments. She would just let roll off her shoulders. And instead, she redirected the conversation to learn about her parents, recognizing
然后，推算出她可能还剩下多少顿晚餐，她计算出她只剩下大约575顿晚餐，也就是说她只剩下8%与父母共进晚餐的机会了。这很有影响力，因为它的作用是促使她抽出时间。无论她觉得自己有多忙，带着这种认知，她都会去参加周日晚上的晚餐。但不仅如此，在晚餐时，它改变了她参与这段时间的方式。你知道，就像她妈妈以前认为的唠叨的话。她会顺其自然地让它过去。相反，她把谈话重定向到了解她的父母，认识到
that their time together is limited and more consequently is really precious and so wanting to make the most of it. You know it's so interesting that I think once something is in the past it's easy to recognize how precious it was. I mean when you think about the walks you had with your son when he was going to preschool across the UCLA campus when you were too busy to smell the roses, you can look back on that now and realize it was really precious. But at the time, you were like, how do I get through this walk really quickly so I can drop him off to get to work?
他们在一起的时间是有限的，更重要的是它真的很珍贵，所以想要充分利用它。你知道，这太有趣了，我觉得一旦某事成为过去，就很容易认识到它是多么珍贵。我的意思是，当你想到你儿子上学前班时，你陪他在UCLA校园散步的情景，那时你太忙而无暇驻足闻闻花香，你现在回过头来看，会意识到那是真的很珍贵。但在当时，你会想：我怎么才能快点走完这段路，好把他放下然后去上班？
There's a real irony there, isn't it, which is when we look back back we can actually see how precious things are, but when we look in the present we often fail to notice that things in fact are precious and are finite. Yeah and that's why it's so important to recognize their preciousness before we've passed them by so that we don't end up feeling regret. Cassie has also found another powerful way to help people achieve a healthier relationship with time. Seek out moments of transcendence. Ah, is the state where your perspective expands well beyond yourself. When we feel our time is scarce, we behave in very limiting ways that we pull into ourselves that we don't think about.
这里面有一种真正的讽刺，不是吗？那就是当我们回首往事时，我们实际上可以看到事情有多么珍贵，但当我们审视现在时，我们经常没有注意到事情其实是珍贵的而且是有限的。是的，这就是为什么在事情过去之前认识到它们的珍贵是如此重要，这样我们就不会最终感到遗憾。卡茜还发现了另一个有力的方法，可以帮助人们与时间建立更健康的联系。寻找超越的时刻。啊，这是一种让你的视野远远超越自我的状态。当我们感到时间匮乏时，我们会以非常局限的方式行事，我们会收缩自己，而不去思考。
We don't have confidence that we can complete all that we sort of want to and ideally would like to do. Whereas by shifting our perspective, expanding our perspective, then it also expands our sense of how much time that we have. Not all of us, of course, can hang out at the Grand Canyon with Mouts a Gap. Most of us are not astronauts who get to see the Earth from out of space. But Cassie argues that there is a simple way for each of us to get out of our own head.
我们没有信心能够完成我们想要且理想中想做的一切。然而，通过转变我们的视角，拓展我们的视角，它也拓展了我们对拥有多少时间的感知。当然，并不是我们所有人都能和莫茨·加普一起去大峡谷闲逛。我们大多数人也不是能够从太空中看到地球的宇航员。但卡茜认为，我们每个人都有一个简单的方法来跳出自己的思维定势。
Exercise is this activity that unfortunately we often don't do when we feel that we don't have a lot of time. I often ask people to complete the sentence. I don't have time to blink. And exercises often, one of those things, that people don't feel they have time to do. And that is not good because exercise research has shown that exercise is wonderful. Increases our cognitive functioning. It increases our self-esteem, so making us feel like we can accomplish what we set out to do. And it's a mood booster.
运动就是这样一项活动，不幸的是，当我们觉得时间不多时，我们往往不做运动。我经常请人们完成这个句子。我连眨眼的时间都没有。而运动往往是人们觉得没有时间去做的那些事情之一。这并不好，因为运动研究表明运动是极好的。它能提高我们的认知功能。它能提升我们的自尊，让我们觉得自己能够完成我们着手去做的事情。而且它是一个情绪助推器。
It makes us feel happier in our subsequent activities. How we experience the limiting nature of time when we feel that time is scarce, we don't feel like we have enough time to complete what we set out to do. But by exercising, through increasing our sense of self-efficacy, it actually expands our sense of what we can complete within our given time. And I am absolutely subject to this. When I don't feel like I have time,
它让我们在接下来的活动中感到更快乐。我们如何体验时间的局限性，当我们觉得时间匮乏时，我们觉得没有足够的时间完成我们着手要做的事情。但通过运动，通过增强我们的自我效能感，它实际上拓展了我们对在给定时间内能完成的事情的感知。而我绝对受制于此。当我觉得自己没有时间时，
my early morning run is the thing that I sacrifice because I'm like, oh, I need to get ready for the day. I need to catch up on email. But in those moments, or at those times where I do make the time, out on that run, as the sun is rising, and I am in flow, I, all of a sudden, don't feel constrained. In fact, I sort of approach the day.
我清晨的跑步是我牺牲的事情，因为我想，哦，我需要为这一天做准备。我需要赶邮件。但在那些时刻，或者在我确实抽出时间的那些时刻，在跑步时，当太阳升起，我进入心流状态时，我突然不觉得受约束了。事实上，我有点像是在迎接新的一天。
I come back, you know, running up the steps, ready for the day, nicer to those around us. We talked about how being time-pour makes us stingier with respect to others. And so it is a very expanding activity. Well, so many of these ideas really speak to the notion that when we are in some ways thinking expansively about our time as opposed to in this very, you know, I'm stressed out, I'm burned out, I don't have time.
我回来了，你知道，跑上台阶，为新的一天做好准备，对身边的人更好。我们讨论了时间贫乏如何让我们对别人更吝啬。所以这是一个非常具有拓展性的活动。嗯，其中的许多理念确实说明了这样一个概念，即当我们以某种方式对我们的时间进行拓展性的思考，而不是处于这种非常，你知道的，我压力很大，我精疲力竭，我没有时间的状态中。
When we have, when we don't have this, you know, the walls are closing in mentality and some ways almost it opens up the possibilities of what we can do with our time. Does it seem that way to you, Kessie? Yeah, so it opens up the possibilities of what we can do with our time. It also makes us think about our time from a broader perspective, from a bird's eye view, where we're thinking more about our years and less hour by hour. And with that broader perspective, then it's more of these questions of what do I value in life? And that influences how we, where we spend our time, spending more on things that are important, rather than just urgent. on things that are important rather than just urgent. In some ways Cassie, so much of this work has been about the idea that we miss the forest
当我们拥有，当我们没有这种，你知道的，四壁合围的心态，在某种程度上几乎它打开了我们如何利用时间可能性的之门。在你看来是这样的吗，卡茜？是的，它打开了我们如何利用时间可能性的之门。它也让我们从更广阔的视角，从鸟瞰的角度来思考我们的时间，我们更多地考虑我们的年，而不是小时复小时。有了这个更广阔的视角，就会有更多这样的问题：我在生活中看重什么？这会影响我们如何，我们在哪里花费时间，把更多的时间花在重要的事情上，而不是仅仅是紧急的事情上。把更多的时间花在重要的事情上，而不是仅仅是紧急的事情上。在某种程度上，卡茜，这项工作的很大一部分都在于这样一个观点，即我们在时间方面只见树木不见森林
for the trees when it comes to time. And in many ways, when we step back and look at the big picture of time, it changes our relationship to time in really profound ways. I'm wondering whether you've taken this insight to heart yourself. How has this changed the way you lead your own life? I absolutely, it influences both how I spend my time spending on activities that are no matter how busy I feel
。在许多情况下，当我们退一步看时间的宏观图景时，它以非常深刻的方式改变了我们与时间的关系。我想知道你自己是否把这个见解记在心里了。这如何改变了你过自己生活的方式？我绝对这样做了，它既影响了我如何花费时间，将时间花在那些无论我感觉有多忙
on those activities that are truly important to me, that connect me with the people I love that allow me to engage with work that does feel purposeful. But I would say even more than the types of activities that I engage with is really how I approach that time. And it's not even so much about how much time you spend, it's really how engaged, how not distracted when I am, so that I'm not missing out. An example that is so precious to me is my morning coffee dates with my daughter.
都对我真正重要、将我与我爱的人联系起来、让我能够从事确实有目标感的工作的活动上。但我可以说，比起我所从事的活动类型，更重要的是我如何对待这段时间。甚至不在于你花了多少时间，而真正在于你的投入程度，当我这样做时我是多么的不分心，这样我就不会错过。一个对我来说非常珍贵的例子是我和女儿早上的咖啡约会。
Once a week, my daughter Lita and I go to a coffee shop. This started actually as a very routine functional activity, where after dropping off her big brother's carpool, on the way into dropping her preschool, which is next to my office, we would stop for coffee because I needed caffeine. She was just tagging along. But what was routine, we turned it into this special tradition. And during that half hour, we would sit
每周一次，我的女儿莉塔和我去一家咖啡馆。这实际上始于一个非常常规的日常功能性活动，在送她大哥哥的拼车之后，在顺路送她去我办公室旁边的学前班之前，我们会停下来买咖啡，因为我需要咖啡因。她只是随行。但把日常的常规，我们把它变成了一个特殊的传统。在那半小时里，我们会坐着
and delight in each other's company. I would drink my coffee, she would drink her hot chocolate, we would munch on quissants and we would just be together. And it was 30 minutes in the week, but that 30 minutes when you ask me how happy I am in life, I am absolutely happy because that 30 minutes is time that I look forward to, that we look forward to. So we anticipate while spending it, we're happy and reflecting back. We remember it as this, and we think about it
享受彼此的陪伴。我会喝我的咖啡，她会喝她的热巧克力，我们会吃牛角面包，我们就会在一起。这是一周中的30分钟，但当问我生活有多幸福时，我绝对是幸福的，因为这30分钟是我所期待的，是我们所期待的时间。所以在期待的同时度过它，我们是快乐的，回味起来。我们将其铭记为这个，我们将其视为
as this source of true connection. And I feel I have a wonderful relationship with my daughter that from this 30 minutes, it is, it colors my week and really the joy that I feel in my life overall. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, Cassie Holmes is a social psychologist at UCLA. She's the author of Happier Hour, how to beat distraction, expand your time, and focus on what matters most.
真正连接的源泉。我觉得我和女儿有着美好的关系，从这30分钟开始，它是，它为我的一周增添了色彩，也确实为我的整体生活带来了快乐。（背景音乐播放中，卡茜·霍姆斯是UCLA的社会心理学家。她是《更快乐的一小时：如何战胜分心、拓展时间和专注于最重要的事情》一书的作者。）
Cassie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's Executive Editor. Our run song here this week is Peter Rishudhi. Peter is a listener and a supporter of the show. He listens to Hidden Brain at the gym, and in an email,
卡茜，非常感谢你今天来到《隐形大脑》。谢谢。本期节目由《隐形大脑》传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、劳拉·科雷尔、克里斯滕·王、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐形大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的片尾曲是彼得·里舒迪。彼得是节目的听众和支持者。他在健身房收听《隐形大脑》，在一封电子邮件中，
he wrote that the show helps him get a better workout on the ellipticals. He said, I can't get off the machine without finishing the episodes. Thus, Hidden Brain also has health benefits. Thank you, Peter, for making Hidden Brain part of your workout routine. And thank you also for your support of the show. If you'd like to join Peter and hundreds of other listeners who've told us that they have our back,
他写道，这个节目帮助他在椭圆机上得到了更好的锻炼。他说，不听完这些集数我无法离开机器。因此，《隐形大脑》也有健康益处。谢谢彼得，感谢你让《隐形大脑》成为你锻炼日常的一部分。也感谢你对节目的支持。如果你想加入彼得以及成百上千位告诉我们他们支持我们的听众，
please go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。